maud marc antoine et le petit arthur
s'en vont discuter avec leurs amis
suffit de quelques clics pour faire
apparaître bien qu'à cédric et anna
[Musique]
règles de confinement oblige ils sont
devenus de fervents adeptes de la
vidéoconférence moi tous les jours avec
ma famille une fois par semaine avec mes
amis ont fait une foire et 5 à 7 ou
encore plus avec c'est sûr avec le
travail je dirais peut-être 400
conférences par jo avec collègues
clients en plus de garder le contact
avec la famille et les amis
c'est aussi un moyen de faire des
activités en groupe chacun dans son coin
[Musique]
facebook messenger vidéo skype et
facetime une multitude d'applications
permettent de faire des vidéoconférences
l'idéal est de trouver celle qui
rassemble le plus de gens dans le groupe
si tout le monde des appareils à paul on
peut utiliser facetime si on a des
appareils android et après on peut
utiliser duo skype permettre comme qui
facilement des ordinateurs des
téléphones mais il faut demeurer prudent
de nombreuses failles de sécurité ont
par exemple été détecté dans
l'application zoom dont l'utilisation a
explosé depuis le début de la crise le
cryptographe y utiliser n'est pas fier à
mener est faible et si quelqu'un est
qu'autant 3 est une conversation vidéo
il est possible pour ces personnes de
décoder l'information et des capable de
lire et d'entendre la conversation
selon les experts que nous avons
consultés facetime et skype sont des
options assez sécuritaire parmi les
applications les plus connus alimente la
proximité
hans fehr s'est fait non je crois qu'on
parle plus à notre famille qu'on parlait
la vidéoconférence ne pourra jamais
remplacer la chaleur du contact humain
mais elle permet néanmoins de briser la
solitude ici olivier bastin réseau
canada montréal